[Music]
well this weekend will be a check
reflect weekend for sports fans here in
our city there's a reason they call this
las vegas the sports and entertainment
capital of the world this weekend is
proof
in las vegas
it
is
always
on this is the place there isn't another
city like it in the world these cold
icemeats ultimate fights this will be
the busiest sports weekend in las vegas
in two years vegas is back and with all
the major sports events coming over 200
000 seats will be occupied at one point
or another from friday through sunday
but there's more than just the fights
nights football soccer racing and
baseball those things are fantastic and
other communities would give their eye
teeth to have those events in their
backyard but it doesn't just stop there
people are staying the night they're
gambling in our casinos they're shopping
in our stores and they're eating in our
restaurants this will be a knockout
weekend a grand slam for fans coming in
from all over the u.s and with the
international crowd starting to come
back
las vegas is well on its way back to
being the entertainment and sports
capital of the world the las vegas
economy is coming back like a hat trick
in the fall and this weekend it's worth
millions tens of millions or perhaps
more i i think that's on the low side
these neon lights